you can use Cleo Columbia's online
catalog to find books journals and other
materials in our collections click on
the guided keyword tab the guided
keyword search gives you some added
flexibility it allows you to combine
terms this is a good method for finding
books about a topic or to narrow down a
broader search and two words and phrases
and choose the fields from the
right-hand drop-down menu when you get
your results list you can sort it I'm
choosing newest first to see the most
recently published books in our
collection when I click on the title of
the book I'm interested in I see a brief
record showing the citation the subject
headings and the location if I click on
full view I can see a table of contents
and a summary as well scrolling down the
page I can see which libraries at
Columbia have this item to find out
where the libraries are located click on
guide this will show you where locations
are listed in Cleo Cleo has lots of
other features like renewing books
online setting limits and using
truncation symbols to get word variants
look at Cleo help for more information